You know, just a good
old-fashioned 18 hour day.
(light hip hop music)
Redeye.
DRock.
Boston.
(dramatic music)
Promised no more red eyes.
I lied.
Hustle always wins.
Hey (censored), it's Gary.
Really well, how are you?
Good, man.
I just want to call you
for five minutes and
see how you're doing.
Just wanted to check in.
Hearing good things.
We didn't really get a chance
to sit down and talk with the
transition from new
business to this account side.
Just wanted to have you get a
sense of how much I thought this,
I'm much more bought into
the upside of your career than
I've been able to
communicate to you.
And I wanted to take a few
minutes and tell you that.
I just think that you're an
unbelievable kid with outrageous
levels of talent and want
you to keep me close if you
need me in any way.
I'm a much bigger cheerleader
and architect of your career
behind the scenes
than I think you know.
I wanted to kinda
gift you that knowledge.
Awesome brother.
Have a great day.
Bye-bye.
You know, I don't understand
why leaders don't understand.
How long was a call?
And I never will understand why
leaders don't understand that a
three minute call can create so
much upside for the individual
on the other side of the call,
you as a leader, and most of all,
which is always my first
priority, the logo at hand.
People always say things like,
"It blows me away how much time
"you have to engage with
your fans on social."
People always say, "I can't
believe you take those
"five minutes to say hello."
What people don't see as much
and what DailyVee allows me to
do is here this three minute
call, three minutes,
180 seconds could be the
difference between this
individual being with us for 10
to 15 years, and he's an amazing
guy, versus gone
in 10 and 15 weeks.
I don't think people get it.
People are your asset.
Whether you're an agency,
whether you sell trinkets,
whether you have a
website, an app.
Anybody who is a business owner,
right now, what you can do it
all by yourself?
And so many of you are solo
entrepreneurs and of course
you can then you are a
solo entrepreneur.
But if you have an organization.
Even me, and I very much make
the analogy of like what did the
Cavs become when Lebron
left and what did the
Cavs become when
Lebron comes back.
Of course, when you have an A+
Hall of Famer on your team you
make everybody better and your
organization runs on that and
there's a difference when I
have run Vayner versus the first
couple of years when I didn't.
When I did Wine Library in that
middle spot, my dad ran in the
beginning and then me in
the middle and then post me.
Yes. Yes.
When you have a star
quarterback, you win.
But it takes every single person
in the org to achieve what you
want to achieve and more
importantly when you have been
blessed and I have been
blessed with 100, 100,
we have 650 employees,
100 superstars in the making.
100 people that I can rattle off
right now on paper that I know
are going to have unbelievable
careers professionally.
Are just incredible people.
Business leaders just
unbelievable managers.
Enormously skilled and just
beginning the process of their
learning it and more importantly
what I can bring to them
over the next 2 to 5 years.
What they can then blossom into
that is an intoxicating feeling.
And very bluntly I'd like
to be doing business
with those hundred people.
Now my goal is probably to have
80 of them still at Vayner five,
10, 15 years from now but 20 of
them to go on and do different
things and I would like
to be in that ecosystem.
Providing the three minutes,
too many of you are
thinking so short term.
You're like yeah you took three
minutes on that but then the guy
leaves and does he does
his own thing and then what.
What?
Then what?
The world continues.
Then you can be
an investor in it.
Then that person can
refer business to you.
Then that person can be a
mentoree as their building their
company and you're helping them
make it better and then they
have an employee that's leaving
and they want a new challenge
and they say you need to
go work for my mentor.
Doing the right thing is
always the right thing.
Maybe I should start having a
theme in saying that in every
god damn episode of this.
Maybe that's the
meme of the show.
Putting that 180 seconds
is always ROI positive.
Hey Momoya, how are you?
Momoya, I'm telling you
with all of my heart
I got another
50 in the last day.
50 every day.
50 like that.
50 like that every day.
I'm telling you.
So Momoya I got really big news.
Thanks Momoya.
Love you. Bye.
That will be good
to have one day.
- [DRock] Oh yeah.
- How I told my mom.
Excited about the The
#AskGaryVee Show search engine.
I think I'm doing a
PSA commercial
in the middle of DailyVee.
But I'm super fired
up about it.
Been working on it
for several months now.
Alexei, big shout out to you.
One of the fans and now a
friend of ours from the show.
Hey I built the thing, Zak
and team have ideated it,
incorporated into
GaryVaynerchuk.com
when you gone there.
It's there.
It's ask.garyvaynerchuk.com.
DRock, do something. Yeah.
Basically every word that I have
uttered in the 200+ episodes of
#AskGaryVee is now searchable.
Like crazy.
I just found the Snapchat
reference from episode 35.
Just super cool.
Amazing.
A lot of you knew this was out
and we talked about it but that
was based on the questions.
Now every answer has been
transcribed so now the full
Monty of my POVs on leadership,
platforms, tactics, no more
tweeting me or emailing me
hoping I'll answer you on a
specific question.
A lot of it has been answered
and now in search form.
And by the way by the way, you
search it, it shows you if it's
in the question or
the answer and then,
DRock you don't
have the film here.
As a matter of fact,
you should probably have
somebody do a screen grab.
Use your editing
skills a little bit.
You do it and it actually takes
you to the exact place,
this you can show
in the episode.
Literally super
excited about it.
Hope it's a
resource for you guys.
This is about making
investments that bring value
1+1, 3 situation.
Brings you guys a lot of value.
Makes it faster, easier for
you to get what you want.
Creates an environment where
there's more awareness about me
because a lot of you will share
these answers and questions just
one plus one equals three.
That is the formula.
Work.
One word.
Good afternoon Sean,
it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
I am well.
Sorry I'm six minutes early.
Good to hear from
you too bother.
We don't have a whole
lot of time and I want to
bring as much value as possible.
Tell me what's going on with
the sandwich world and more
importantly what
can I help you with?
(dramatic music)
4:30 in the afternoon,
already did a redeye to Boston
I've got a couple hours of sleep
which is nice, thank God.
Got up had an important meeting.
A new business opportunity
we'll see how that goes.
Just been banging out
work in my email and now
if that wasn't enough
we got three calls, get in,
got a Skype interview got to
run to a client meeting with one
of my leaders Steve Schutzman,
that would be good.
Excited about that.
Then I'm going to pop out, we're
going to film an #AskGaryVee
episode on the streets.
Is that going to
be double camera?
You're going to be DailyVee--
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Staphon's going
to be doing that.
I love that.
That's interesting.
That'll be good.
And then family dinner so
you don't see that stuff.
We've talked about
that in the past.
I'm sorry that I don't show
as much of that 'cause people
always like you never
you have a family time.
I do, we've
decided not to show it.
But then DRock will have to hang
around and probably edit because
at 10:15 I have a
drinks meeting.
It's a real hustle.
You know?
You can do what most people want
to do it after a red eye they go
home and just kind of relax
that day and recuperate which
depending on your
body is appropriate.
But we all have
strengths and weaknesses.
One of my strengths
is my energy level.
No question.
And I take advantage of that.
Your actions need to
map what you want.
And so I want it.
And so I'll put in the work.
I'm just watching them trying
to figure out some angles.
I'm like what are they doing,
what are they wearing,
how are they rolling?
I love watching this.
This is all I give
it a shit about.
This is all I care about.
Show me your actions kids,
show me your actions.
Sorry Waze.
I'm sorry for ever doubting you.
Technology 1, human emotion 0.
Sup man?
How are you guys?
- [Man] Gary.
- Sup? Good to see you.
- [Doorwoman] How you doing, Gary?
- I'm doing well.
How are you?
- [Doorwoman] Good.
- Good.
Hey man. So the wine
sold really well.
Of course.
I agree.
Really good.
Happy birthday, Cort.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] Go ahead Britt.
That's a real big one.
Ty.
Cool.
Okay, man.
Good, I'm happy with today.
How did Liz and George say?
- Sign this for my mom?
- Sure. What's her name?
Tyler's mom?
- [Tyler] Johanna.
- Are you serious?
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- That's amazing.
My mom is Tamara and
your mom's name is Johanna.
She likes me now or something?
Reminder, I'm not in tomorrow.
I'm in middle school
talking career day.
- Yeah.
You can pop out
of this this is...
- Hey DRock.
- [Gary] Making his
check in the box.
- DailyVee debut.
- Hey brother.
Good to see you.
- [Man on Skype] You're just
ambitious and I think that
freaks some people out.
How dare he think he is
going to buy the Jets but
I have no doubts.
I just don't know what
your timeline is but
you just give me a clue.
- Yeah, long-term, man.
I'm super pumped.
Honestly, back to being
addicted to the process,
I actually secretly think
I sabotage myself.
I actually deep down if you
really want me to kind of open
up here a little bit, I actually
think I could probably get there
sooner but I want
to string it out.
I love the foreplay of business.
- [Man on Skype] I love that.
I am stealing that.
- I think I'm
going to get there.
I just for some weird reason,
this is my own romance
and maybe this is a flaw but
it is mine and I love it.
And I am enjoying it.
I actually weirdly
think I'd be happier
buying the Jets at 70 than 55.
I don't know how to fully
synthesize that for everybody
but I just really
love the climb.
I love the climb. I do.
I like the red eye that I took
last night. Secretly.
And listen I'm taking care of my
health and am cutting out a lot
of time for my family
'cause I don't want to have the
casualties that come along
with the love the climb.
I don't want to die
young from bad health.
I don't want to lose my
family from being too much of a
workaholic so when I'm aware
of the casualties but I would
suffocate if I couldn't play
this game the way that
I want to play.
- [Man on Skype] Well said.
- Talk to you.
- [Man on Skype] Thanks
so much for your time.
- Stay well. Bye-bye.
Thanks Bry.
- [Man on Skype]
That was awesome, man.
Thank you so much.
- Love you man.
Good luck. Take care.
Bye-bye.
Trout, can you take my bag to
the house or Nate or somebody
that goes up there?
- [Trouty] Yeah.
- [Gary] Sup brother?
- [Man] How you doing man?
Good seeing you.
- Thanks for email earlier.
- Oh, thank you
for replying back.
- Nice sneaks.
- [Tyler] You did that?
- Yeah, this weekend.
- [Tyler] How was it?
- [Woman] It was great.
- This used to be my thing.
The sneaker lottery.
- [Tyler] Amsterdam is
absolutely the best.
- [Woman] It was awesome.
- [Tyler] This was like a
second round pick too.
A lot of value.
Hackenberg right there.
Hackenberg kind of kicks.
- [Man] Sup?
- Sup?
This is us?
- Yeah, I'm getting
in the car with you.
- Okay, good.
- Hello.
- [Driver] How are you?
(dramatic music)
- Stairs, the
bar's to your right.
- What's that?
- Go in through here,
upstairs bar's to your left.
Alright, peace out boys.
- See ya.
Where we going DRock?
The lobby in the back.
How are you?
- [Woman] How are you?
- Good to see you.
So long.
Good to see you.
- [Woman] You look so good.
- How are you?
- Good. We're kind of in
the cut back here.
- Oh, yes my vlog.
You know, just a good
old-fashioned 18 hour day.
All good stuff.
Good meetings.
Some nice family time tonight.
Working hard. Hustling.
Trying to make it happen.
One day at a time.
Telling you right now.
This is all it's going to be.
You know, I can say
the grind, the hustle.
But the reality is
going to exhaust you.
You're going to
get tired of this.
I'm just telling you right now.
It's going to be
day in and day out.
And so for the ones that come in
and figure out the religion and
are able to deploy it
against their hopes and
dreams and wants.
That's my ambition and
for the people that
get the gist but are
still entertained because
it is escapism the way
I use the Jets, Mazel Tov.
I love having you and I
hope you're enjoying it but
forewarning,
if DRock doesn't get tired
of it and what have you,
this is what it looks like.
This is what it's looked
like the last 20 years.
This is just what it is.
It's not going to change.
There may be funny moments.
I might come up with clever
sayings per episode
but it's a fucking grind.
24/7/365
for life.